the covered 19 virus is rapidly
spreading Europe's open borders are
closing much of America shutting down
its deadly effects are being felt around
the world at least five hundred and
sixty-five people are dead one Hospital
reportedly receiving a new patient every
five minutes and the global economy is
crashing a financial panic Rock world
markets again today I think it's clear
we're going into recession it's become
clear only in the last few days exactly
the scale of the challenge that the
world now faces with this virus
governments are taking unprecedented
steps to monitor and contain the highly
contagious disease and save lives we
have to get this problem fixed without
drastic measures it would overwhelm any
health system in the world but what are
the best strategies to prevent the
disease from spreading and welcome the
world learn from China Singapore and
South Korea some of the first countries
that were forced to react to this
pandemic
[Music]
kovat 19 was first detected in China and
despite early reluctance to admit to the
outbreak the country has shown that it
is possible to halt the spread of the
virus by putting in place extreme
measures never in history had a country
taken such severe measures and applied
them so rigorously and even thuggish ly
where where they felt necessary in order
to try and stop the spread of a new
disease the Chinese government puts 60
million people living in Hebei province
on lockdown for nearly two months as
well as introducing other measures it
appears to have worked China has had
more coronavirus cases than any other
country but following the lockdown the
number of new infections has been
falling it's gone from thousands of new
cases per day in February to just a
handful of new cases each day in
mid-march I think that actually it's
kind of shown what's possible and set a
new norm
china managed to suppress coronavirus
the latest research from scientists at
Imperial College London at British
University suggests that other countries
may benefit from a similarly drastic
approach they predicted how two
different strategies to fight covered 19
might pan out in America and in Britain
one is what we call mitigation which is
to try and lower the intensity of the
outbreak at its most extreme in order to
cut deaths and to help health services
cope with it mitigation focuses on the
ill and vulnerable isolating them at
home to try and stop the spread Britain
has around eight critical care beds for
every 100,000 people if nothing was done
to curb coronavirus demand for critical
care would outstrip capacity by 30 times
the most successful mitigation
strategies could flatten the curve
dramatically reducing peak demand by
two-thirds but the system would still be
overwhelmed eight times over and many
people would still die researchers from
Imperial College say a suppression
approach like that seen in China would
be more likely to save lives
suppression where you try and squash the
disease down so there's actually
temporarily dies out in the population
and that you need stronger social
distancing and you need to sustain it
for longer suppression imposes social
distancing on whole populations not just
those with symptoms and may also require
school closures for up to five months
modeling suggests it can keep demand for
critical care under maximum capacity
meaning doctors would be able to treat
all of the most seriously ill patients
saving lives but as soon as these
measures are lifted the virus can
quickly return overwhelming health
systems
that's because keeping people away from
each other means they don't catch the
disease and so don't develop the
immunity that comes with fighting it so
this is a very sobering assessment it's
obviously a model but it's the best
information we have and it's the best
basis for thinking about the progress of
this disease all eyes will be on China
to see whether it can stop the virus
from coming back in a second wave as it
lifts its restrictions but one thing has
already become clear from China the
economic cost of suppression is very
high if you look at the figures this
week coming out of China about the
economic consequences they've been
several times worse than most forecasts
retail sales have gone down twenty
percent they are expected to go down
about four percent fixed asset
investment has gone down twenty four
percent that's many times more than
people are expecting this presents the
world with a real dilemma
is going to be hard to
deal with and it's going to be even more
costly to deal with and how do you begin
to balance and reconcile those two very
very difficult things despite the
serious economic consequences many
countries are opting for suppression
policies in order to save lives a day of
Samba language heralding state
interventions unprecedented in modern
peacetime the advice was clear a request
to the public to do something difficult
disruptive trakone Ian Francis just
hours away from a nationwide lockdown
but must measures be as extreme as those
taken in China one Southeast Asian
country has so far been a role model for
how to suppress the virus early the
number of new cases per day in Singapore
has been very low the country has had
fewer than 350 confirmed coronavirus
cases in total far less than would be
expected given its close links with
China and so far no one in the country
has died from the virus it's done it by
very very clear messaging here in
Singapore we have all along taken covert
19
with the utmost seriousness the advice
that Singapore has given its citizens it
was up front that this was a big threat
that it was going to be difficult and
these are the measures that people needs
to do it we have to be mentally prepared
for the number of infected cases in
Singapore to go up where you see for
instance I have to say regrettably in
the United States very mixed messaging
the undermining of officials the
confused contradictory messages coming
out of the White House that doesn't help
it may now be too late for many
countries to prevent the virus from
taking hold but governments could learn
from South Korea where coronavirus
infected more than 800 people per day at
its peak there was a moment at this when
it looked as if South Korea was in real
trouble because the disease got away
from them that all sorts of cases
started popping up unexpectedly
yet its government managed to suppress
the disease through a national program
of testing coupled with aggressive case
tracking and isolation it was highly
effective at reducing infection rates
South Korea had a clearer sense of where
the disease was what measures to take
and that has helped it isolate people
and to shut down this disease South
Korea has tested around 310 thousand
people for coronavirus apart from China
other countries have lagged far behind
despite pleas from the World Health
Organization you cannot fight a fire
blindfolded we have a simple message for
all countries test test test
as the pandemic develops testing could
be key to identifying who is safe to be
in public including those who have
already had the virus and who should be
in isolation the testings going to have
to change in future the tests that are
being used at the moment which detect
fragments of genetic material from the
virus in people's bodies isn't a very
good test for those who have recovered
from the disease because that material
might have disappeared instead you need
to look for antibodies to the disease in
people's blood and these are the tests
that you need to start doing at a high
level so you can identify the population
that is immune
China Singapore and South Korea have
provided valuable lessons for the rest
of the world they have proved that
suppression in the short term can be
effective but until a vaccine is
developed which will take some months at
the very least strict measures will
remain in place it'll be so demanding
and demoralizing that I think that
society's willingness to go through this
again and again and again which is what
the modeling suggests is required if
you're going to suppress the disease
altogether I don't think people will
tolerate that governments have to give
people hope an opportunity to be able to
for lives to return to normal and they
need to find ways to get money to
businesses so that they don't collapse
and the economy isn't really severely
harmed by the disease that's a very tall
order and even with so much uncertainty
about the coronavirus policymakers are
going to have to think and act faster
than in a long long time thank you for
watching if you have your own questions
about the corona virus pandemic then
leave them in the comments below we'll
put them to our resident coronavirus
experts and publish a film with their
answers hit the subscribe button to get
an alert for when we publish this film
and click the link opposite to get the
latest reporting from The Economist on
coppered 19 and its global impact
[Music]
you